نَحْيَا فِي عُلْبَةِ أَلْوَانْ *** هَلْ تَعْرِفُنَا يَا فَنَّانْ
بِالبَهْجَةِ نَمْلأُ أعَينَكُمْ  *** والفَرْحَةِ نَحْنُ الأَلْوَانْ
نَحْنُ الأَلْوَانْ
ألوان ألوان  ألوان   ألوان ألوان  ألوان
أَنَا أَحْمَرُ لَوْنُ الطَمَاطِمْ *** أَنَا أَيْضًا لَوْنُ التُّفَاحْ
Red  أنا أحمر أحمر أحمر
أَنَا أَصْفَرْ لَوْنُ المُوْزَةْ  *** لَوْنُ الشَّمْسِ بِكُلِ صَبَاحْ
Yellow  أصفر أصفر أصفر
أَنَا أَخْضَرُ لَوْنُ الفلفلْ *** لَوْنُ شَّجَرة فوق التل
Green   أخضر أخضر أخضر
أَنَا أَسْوَدُ لَوْنُ الفَحْمِ  ***  لَوْنُ غُرَابٍ طَارَ وَصَاحْ
Black أسود أسود أسود
ألوان ألوان  ألوان   ألوان ألوان  ألوان
أَنَا أَبْيَضُ لَوْنُ الغَيْمَةْ  ***  والَّلبَنُ كَلَوْنِي يَا صَاحْ
White أبيض أبيض أبيض
أَنَا بُنِّي لَوْنُ الأَخْشَابْ ***   لَوْنُ الشِيُكُولاَتَةْ الجَذَّابْ
Brown  بني بني بني
أَنَا وَرْدِيْ لَوْنُ الأَزْهَارْ ***    في الْحَلْوَى لَوْنِي يا صِغارْ
Pink  وردي وردي وردي
أَنَا أَزْرَقُ لَوْنُ البُحُورِ ***   والحُوتُ بِلَوْنِي مَشْهُورْ
Blue أزرق أزرق أزرق
أَمَّا أَنَا فَالبُرْتُقَالِي  ***   بِالجَزَرِ والبُرْتُقَالِ
Orange برتقالي
نَحْيَا فِي عُلْبَةِ أَلْوَانْ *** هَلْ تَعْرِفُنَا يَا فَنَّانْ
بِالبَهْجَةِ نَمْلأُ أعَينَكُمْ  *** والفَرْحَةِ نَحْنُ الأَلْوَانْ
نَحْنُ الأَلْوَانْ
ألوان ألوان  ألوان   ألوان ألوان  ألوان